mitten am tag mitten auf berlins größten
bekanntesten boulevard
was spricht das für das täterprofil
offen machen sich die täter ja äußerst
sicher gefühlt
wie der polizeisprecher schon bestätigt
hat war es auf der einen seite relativ
organisiert aber auf der anderen seite
auch ziemlich dreist also von vorsichtig
kann ja weiß gott nicht gerade sein und
die tarnung wirkt auf den ersten blick
geschickt man könnte es als die
strategien heiligen in plain sight also
etwas ist so offensichtlich ich meine
orange ist eine signalfarbe sie haben
wortwörtlich signalfarben getragen
aber wenn etwas so auffällig ist ist es
aus zeugen perspektive schon fast so
kurios oder so offensichtlich dass man
dahinter manchmal nichts böses vermutet
aber ganz ausgefeilt war die tarnung
dann doch nicht denn sie sind eine
großer brutalität vorgegangen
sie haben sturmmasken getragen das war
waren eben nicht einfach müllmänner die
säcke tragen würde ich sagen ist eine
ziemlich gute tarnung die ziemlich
unauffällig ist müllmänner die
sturmmasken tragen und mit waffen und
reizgas so brutal vorgehen und auch zwei
personen verletzten und eine davon sogar
mutmaßlich schwer
das ist dann wiederum alles andere als
unauffällig deswegen wurde es ja auch
von vielen zeugen glücklicherweise
gefilmt was glauben sie denn wer könnte
hinter so einer tat stecken ja die
handschrift dieser tat deutet natürlich
erstmal auf organisierte kriminalität
oder aufklaren kriminalität hin gerade
in berlin ist es im letzten jahr zu
einer häufung ähnlicher taten gekommen
beispielsweise am 15 dezember haben drei
räuber ein geldtransporter vor einem
ikea in berlin überfallen und haben auch
da die geldboten mit waffen bedroht und
sind dann mit einem weißen auto
geflüchtet ebenfalls mit gestohlenen
kennzeichen sowie auch bei diesem fall
auf dem kudamm und wenige tage danach
wurden zwei geldboten am park center in
berlin treptow ebenfalls überfallen auch
hier drei tatverdächtige und auch hier
sind sie mit reizgas vorgegangen das
heißt es gibt nicht nur eine häufung
solcher taten sondern es gibt auch eine
häufung von taten mit einem ähnlichen
modus operandi ähnlicher vorgehensweise
auch wenn es einige unterschiede gibt
das heißt jetzt gilt es natürlich für
die ermittler erst mal zu prüfen ob es
zusammenhänge zu diesen anderen taten
gibt und ob es verbindungen in die
organisierte kriminalität oder
kleinkriminalität gibt aber da muss man
denen natürlich noch ein bisschen zeit
geben das zu ermitteln
aber ich sage es mal so dass
organisierte krimi
kriminalität und clans dafür bekannt
sind gerade in berlin geldtransporter
banken und kaufhäuser zu überfallen
das ist ein offenes geheimnis und
deswegen ist das natürlich auch erstmal
der der erste verdacht alles andere wäre
naiv
lassen sie uns noch einmal über diese
außergewöhnliche tarnung man kann es
eigentlich schon vor gar nicht nahrung
wenn leuchtend orange sprechen und sagen
ja auch die menschen die diesen überfall
beobachtet haben berichtet ich ging erst
davon aus es ist ein film nutzten die
täter vielleicht auch diese momente der
irritation man sieht müllmänner mit
waffen rumfuchteln war das etwas was
ihnen quasi in die karten ausspielen
konnte in dieser situation
ich meine dass kriminelle sich tarnen
und andere identitäten oder sich als
amtsträger verkleiden ist ja etwas was
keineswegs neu ist gerade es gibt viele
betrugsmaschen bei den täter als
polizisten auftreten es gab schon
banküberfälle wo personen als polizisten
verkleidet das gemacht haben und
polizisten sind deshalb so eine beliebte
tarnung oder beliebte tarnuniformen weil
dann auch die waffen eine legitimation
haben wenn sie einen polizist sehen der
mit einer waffe in eine bank geht dann
würden sie nicht die polizei rufen sie
würden vielleicht filmen und sagen krass
ich bin gerade zeuge wie die polizei
einen banküberfall stoppt aber sie
würden wahrscheinlich nicht glauben dass
das der bankräuber ist das heißt
polizisten auch die leider rentner
betrügen oder alle möglichen arten von
betrugsmaschen machen dass kriminelle
sich als polizisten verkleidet ist
bekannt es gab auch schon ganz kuriose
einbrüche wo personen als weihnachtsmann
oder sonstiges verkleidet das ganze
begehen aber müllmänner am hellichten
tage auf dem auf dem kudamm in berlin
ist schon ich weiß nicht ob es einmalig
ist aber mindestens mal ungewöhnlich was
bedeutet denn eigentlich coruna für
diese art von verbrechen jetzt haben wir
die meisten geschäfte geschlossen also
alle geschäfte geschlossen
die banken sind auch nicht so
aufgestellt wie sonst bleiben dann nur
noch die geldtransporte übrig die jetzt
als zielscheibe für derartige überfälle
gelten könnten kronach bringt natürlich
auch die kriminalität insbesondere die
clans und organisierte kriminalität zu
handeln oder um zu denken weil manche
der klassischen einkommensquellen wenn
man es denn so bezeichnen will
ausgetrocknet sind beispielsweise
dinge wie ladendiebstähle gehen seit
langer zeit nicht mehr einbrüche gehen
auch nicht weil alle leute zu hause sind
und das meiden natürlich einbrüche
einbrecher und auch viele andere delikte
sind so einfach nicht mehr möglich ich
würde auch behaupten ich weiß gar nicht
genau wie es gerade in der
drogenkriminalität ausgeht aber wenn ich
eine hypothese aufstellen müsste würde
ich sagen wenn die klubs geschlossen
sind und keine partys mehr möglich sind
dann werden auch weniger zumindest von
den party drogen konsumiert so dass auch
das etwas sein können wo das einkommen
teilweise wegfällt das heißt hier ist
auch die kriminalität zur kreativität
gezwungen und geldtransporter zu
überfallen
da merkt man gerade in berlin innerhalb
der letzten 12 bis 14 monate eine
gewisse häufung das heißt es könnte
durchaus ein delikt sein was gerade
jetzt interessant ist weil viele andere
delikte nicht mehr möglich sind und
warum sind geldtransporter jetzt gerade
in corona zeiten sogar besser möglich zu
überfallen als in anderen zeiten weil
die straßen leer sind
das ist ja ein delikt was auf der straße
passiert das sind darauf angewiesen
schnell wegzukommen von dem eigentlichen
ort des geschehens und da helfen
natürlich leere straßen ich würde
behaupten
jeder der schon mal um 10 uhr unter der
woche am kudamm auto gefahren ist weiß
dass es eine zeit ist wo berufsverkehr
viele viele shopping touristen und so
weiter es ist dort normalerweise so voll
dass das gar nicht möglich wäre aber im
moment sind die straßen leer und im
moment geht ja auch niemand oder kann ja
auch niemand shoppen gehen
denn weshalb das ein delikt ist was
durchaus auch wo es auch ein
zusammenhang mit corona geben könnte
dass das gerade einfach besonders
praktisch ist ja lassen sie uns noch mal
auf den ort zurück kommen der berliner
ku dann der prachtboulevard hat warum
suchen sich täter so einen ort aus
selbst wenn er leer ist in corona zeiten
aber dennoch so prominent so
offensichtlich man hätte ja auch
irgendwie geldtransporter halten ja
vielleicht auch ein etwas versteckten
ecken
was bedeutet das für seinen täterprofil
wenn man so etwas macht insbesondere
bedeutet die ganze falle analyse oder
auch das profiling bedeutet ja aus
täterperspektive zu denken und ich würde
behaupten dass das aus täterperspektive
vielleicht die falsche frage ist denn
aus dieser tat spricht ja eine ganz
erstaunliche dreistigkeit das heißt die
gedanken die sie sich man hätte man das
nicht vorsichtiger machen können hätte
man nicht in ruhigeren ort wählen können
dahinter steckt ja das motiv vorsichtig
zu sein
und bloß nicht erwischt zu werden ich
glaube aber eher dass im kopf der täter
eine so große sich selbstsicherheit ist
dass sie überhaupt keine angst vor
strafverfolgung haben und deshalb auch
in dieser in dieser art der dreistigkeit
also wirklich auf der auf einer der
berühmtesten shoppingmeilen deutschlands
das am hellichten tage zu tun
das spricht dafür dass angst vor strafe
und konzern baut evidenz wie die
amerikaner sagen hier überhaupt keine
rolle spielt woher kommt dieses
selbstbewusstsein möglicherweise daher
dass man in der vergangenheit bereits
damit davon gekommen ist wenn sie einmal
davonkommen zweimal davon kommen dreimal
davon kommen dann sind sie beim vierten
mal ziemlich selbstsicher und wenn sie
dann die frage stellen warum dort warum
kein vorsichtigere ort dann ist
möglicherweise die antwort weil
vorsichtig sein aus sicht der täter gar
keine wesentliche kategorie ist ja mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich jedes nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren